hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et tu table le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger nous fait envie mais
voulons mimolette
quand j'ai froid elle se fait lumière
j'ai mal ce fut rien
à midi tout dans un silence quand je
souffre rennes souffre avec moi quand je
ris elle rit aux éclats avec mon public
mes chansons sont souvent pour elle elle
sera toujours merveille quand je ne suis
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sens
[Musique]
allez on y va attention aux principaux
cas djezzy dont way we faisait hier
matin kenji j'aimerais qu'on se fasse
moi j'aimerais qu'on soit tous les deux
comme ça vaut trois tubes je vais pas
trop chanter et puis à un moment il ya
chico et les gypsies qui vont venir nous
rejoindre
est ce qu'on peut se faire vas-y fais
quoi color gitano d'abord pour démarrer
comme rita gitane je préfèrerais
[Musique]
alors j'imagine démarche vêtu
la musique
c
à jeumont histoire
alors
les ados
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il adore